hey I have something delightful for you
today in the voicemail segment I have
today a caller that may be the most
endearing caller we've ever had it
sounds like just a delightful sweet
older lady who is leaving me a beautiful
voicemail and there's just a perfect
little touch to this you can hear my
show playing in the background
she didn't pause the show to call in and
leave us this voicemail or if he's
listening on the radio if he didn't turn
down her radio take a look I love this
is my new favorite caller hey I really
love your show and I do not think Tom is
going to warm his way out of this I just
can't even believe that he is such an
idiot and he is running our country that
is just unconscionable to me let me show
David and there's my show continuing to
play in the background I love that that
is my new favorite caller I'm imagining
that her name is Gladys and I don't know
why I'm imagining that but we that that
is just absolutely heartwarming the
keeping the show playing in the
background you couldn't do it any better
if you were to stage it it wouldn't
sound any different which maybe it is
actually staged and I fell for it but I
loved it and that's that's my new
favorite caller Gladys or whatever your
name is we absolutely love you here okay
on the bonus show we will be talking
about could coronavirus accelerate
automation of jobs in the United States
and around the world number 2 Denmark
and Poland are not going to bail out
companies that are registered in
offshore tax havens can you imagine the
United States doing something similar
I can't we will discuss it and Facebook
has announced announced they will be
taking down some but not all posts that
are promoting protests against
stay-at-home orders
people on both sides are furious about
this some saying why would they take any
posts down others saying they should be
taking all of the posts down free speech
is being discussed people
misunderstanding the First Amendment of
course is a factor and we will discuss
that on today's bonus show how do you
get access to the bonus show simple
quick easy two ways number one get a
membership get a membership at join
pakman.com you will instantly get access
to the bonus show option to make a
pledge on patreon of $5 a month or more
that's patreon.com slash david pakman
show that's the second way to get access
to the bonus show either way producer
Pat will join me we will discuss all of
these stories and more I will see you
then or otherwise tomorrow